like I said when we first started this
podcast I've been so intentional about
keeping things between us between us you
are not an internet piece of clickbait
for me you're my everything babe I
[__] love you so much now I wanted to
just point out a couple things you can
kind of tell when the relationship
Dynamic is just a bit off when the guy
is putting the woman on a pedestal now
you know it's one thing if she's like a
22 year old virgin right but this is a
31 year old model that's that's been
around everybody you know and you're to
the point where you're like crying and
he said you're my everything and I
really think that men are in a dangerous
position nowadays when they put a woman
so high on a pedestal that she's
literally his everything